hello everyone I'm Laura Ingram this is
Ingram Ango from New York City tonight X
gonna give it to you that's the focus of
tonight's
angle all right if you think Democrats
are truly worried about election
interference you're not paying attention
people when they obsessed about Russia's
meddling in the election that was only
to hurt Trump and if you think that they
believe democracy is at risk if Trump
wins the White House you're not
listening
these same people trash The credibility
of our doj and our FBI they've destroyed
our once secure border they have done
enormous damage to the Public's faith in
these Democratic institutions they don't
care about democracy and know if you
think liberals still cared about free
speech I think you're stuck in a late
1960s Time
Warp liberals now Embrace government
censorship they Embrace government
surveillance of innocent Americans if
those Americans are their political
opponents now the former Free Speech
crowd are filled with totalitarians they
the new totalitarians because they
believe people like Trump and D santis
need to be stopped by any means
necessary yeah they have civil rights
not really and of course Elon Musk he
falls into that same category Persona n
grada yesterday he was pressed The
Exodus of sponsors from X over a Media
Matters campaign against him for
allegedly anti-semitic content on
Twitter well he was the F-bomb heard
around the
world there was all of the criticism
there was advertisers leaving we talked
to Bob Iger I hope they stop you hope uh
don't advertise you don't want them to
advertise no what do you
mean if somebody's going to try to
Blackmail me with advertising black m
with money go
yourself but go
yourself is that clear that's how I feel
don't
advertise now to many his response was
crash we kind of got it on the first
F-bomb but I really thought about this
in many ways musk is voicing the same
frustration that millions and millions
of Americans feel about what they see
happening to this country I mean they're
not multi-billionaires but they see
what's happening freedoms that we once
took for granted are under
assault in none are more important than
the freedom of
speech freedom of speech you have to say
when is it relevant it's only relevant
when when someone you don't like can say
something you don't like or it it has no
meaning um and and as soon as you sort
of you know throw in the towel and
concede to censorship it is only a
matter of time before someone censors
you you cannot back down he is 100%
correct but then again as musk himself
conceded in the quick response world of
social media he gave the corporate
overlords who want to destroy him an
easy opening and of course they took it
already IBM Apple Disney Warner Brothers
and others have pulled all their ads
from
X and the media wall groups they
gleefully celebrated the threat to musk
$44 billion investment advertisers have
been really fleeing X left right and
Center over growing concerns that musk
has Amplified anti-Semitism and racism
this is not an enlightened super ego
this is this is a guy in a lot of
trouble on stage I think just
dissembling a bit some men just want to
watch the world burn and I I think that
completely applies uh to this scenario
none of them can concerned about free
speech at all none of them now at this
point I think most everyone understands
that the business establishment all
those advertisers it's aligned with
government power Brokers here and abroad
who want to restrict Free Speech as much
as possible at some point they've all
come to the conclusion that regular work
a day people have too much freedom and
that a free flow of information doesn't
really work any longer absorbing too
much Freedom too much speech no that's
not a good thing and mainly about how
the establishment has been failing them
for decades they're learning that
information so that information must be
tightly
controlled now to that end most media
Outlets are becoming more and more
closely aligned with establishment
political figures now in the United
States for example most of our press is
simply an extension of the Biden
campaign that's why they report
uncritically about any and every
investigation into Donald Trump no
matter how tainted by
politics this is the third arraignment
for Mr Trump in four months and the most
serious of the indictments he faces
Trump now faces serious charges the
indictment of former president Trump
facing the most serious legal threat of
his life now just like Trump uh Elon
Musk is a threat to these folks because
he owns x and x allows normal people to
access information that's impossible to
find in much of the mainstream
press that means both the political
establishment and the business
establishment are trying to put X out of
business now that's the real reason for
any boycott none of these corporate
Chiefs actually care about what musk
believes or even what musk and X are
doing and this certainly isn't about
curving
anti-Semitism look at how the media
covers the pramas madness in our streets
and at our universities that's that's
all you need to look at see how much
they care about anti-Semitism there's
plenty of anti-Semitism out there that
the media pretends just doesn't exist
because of course it comes from their
own political
bedfellows right to Reb Isel go to hell
isra go to Israelis and the Zionist pigs
finally got what was coming to
them would you love her at a party now
are all these companies pulling out of
the univers unities all their
sponsorship of universities where true
hate is allowed to Fester of course not
they'd never do that the truth is they
just want to shut X down to make it
harder for voters to have access to
information that would make the
establishment
uncomfortable everyone knows this
including musk and he's trying to tell
them that they will not intimidate him
into silence now we'll have to see if
they try to use the legal process to
shut him down like G given that they're
using the legal process against Trump I
don't think any of us are going to be
surprised if they do the same thing in
some way against X or musk and then
against the rest of us and that's the
angle hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else